apple's new m2 chip for the mac is  coming sooner than you think potentially  as soon as a rumored march 8th apple  event according to various sources  including mark german who just put out a  new report over the weekend that is  probably the most important confirmation  we've received to this day even though  the m2 chip will sound like it's better  the m1 pro and max chips will still have  major performance advantages including  raw power ssd speed and ram speed as  well among other differences like the m1  max actually coming with two video  encoders as well as two sets of prores  encoders slash decoders while i fully  expect the m2 chip to stick with just  one geekbench 5 single core test m2 chip  will actually have an awesome  performance boost over the m1 chips in  the multi-core performance it's still  slower than the bend 8 core m1 pro chip  for the graphics side of things we can  see the exact same thing